today everybody is talking about the
Yukon mac-and-cheese kid I don't know if
you've been checking this out online but
a student at the University Connecticut
showed up drunk at the cafeteria got
into a huge fight when they wouldn't
serve him bacon jalapeno mac and cheese
yeah and of course as happens with
everything now some was there taking
video of the whole encounter he was
abusive to the staff for nine minutes
and a lot of people are really angry at
this kid this is just a tiny part of
this online video that's gone viral it's
just depressing yeah well anyway a lot
of people upset but UConn has already
turned this negative experience into a
positive
take a look you're so drunk you can't
even feel your face get your ass down to
UConn for the taste everyone's talking
about that's right the king bacon
jalapeno McEntee
[Applause]
you can commissary bacon jalapeno mac
and cheese
it's worth getting arrested
wasn't that a great clip subscribe to my
youtube channel for an endless supply of
me
[Laughter]